>>Peggy: This community had been
without a school for about 25 years.
It was a community on the decline.
It had gone from a stable middle
class area to high density,
high transient rate, poverty.
So, this community
didn't have a center.
>>Narrator: Five years ago, Principal
Peggy Bryan faced an exciting
yet daunting task.
She was asked to build
a new elementary school
and assemble a new team of
educators to address the needs
of this diverse community.
>>Peggy: The superintendent said to
me, essentially, she wouldn't want
to walk onto this campus and see
something she's ever seen before.
So that was the starting place.
What we did is we divided up the
prospective parents of the families
that would be coming to Sherman Oaks,
and we called them up one by one.
And asked them if we could come
out and spend 30 minutes with them
and hear what their ideas were
for the school their
children would be attending.
High interest in technology,
that was key.
They really wanted to see
art education be a big part
of the school.
And the third thing they said is,
"If you could communicate with us
as much as possible, please do."
>>Osvaldo: When Peggy approached
me to come in to Sherman Oaks,
I jumped at the opportunity because
I knew this was going to be the place
where we were going to look
at each child individually
and not group them, or not
teach them all the same way.
And it was really nice to have
the support of the staff and all
of us having the same philosophy,
which is child-centered and believing
that each child can
succeed no matter what.
To me this is the place
where I became a teacher.
>>Teacher: Remember today
we're just looking for pictures
and places, names of places.
>>Narrator: Peggy considers the
teachers at Sherman Oaks her equals.
She creates a culture where
teachers can do their best work
and are encouraged to
learn from one another.
>>Peggy: The staff
is an amazing group.
And they just exude enthusiasm
and belief and confidence.
And it's contagious.
I always turn to the staff and
say, "What do you think about this?
What do you think about that?"
Everyone has an equal voice.
I like to provide that kind of
environment for them, just like they,
then, provide for the kids.
I come to work every day saying I'm
going to get in every classroom.
And most of the time
I accomplish that.
It gives me a personal
connection with the kids.
And they're like my
kids, all 466 of them.
>>Okay, What's happening?
>>Teacher: They're working on
journals and then they're going
to come and just go to free choice.
>>Peggy: What I need to do is
keep a sense of the big picture.
My goal is, at any given time,
to keep track of the pulse
of the school, to know, in
general, what are trends are
and what are next steps are.
>>Sandra: Peggy at the school
has a great leadership role.
And I've admired her since I met her.
>>Peggy: Okay, here's the Internet.
Show me how to get on.
>>Sandra: She's the best
role model that I've seen
for life long learning,
which is what we promote
for our kids at this school, too.
>>Peggy: We wanted technology
accessible to kids all the time.
So we don't have a technology lab.
You wouldn't have a
pencil lab now would you?
So our kids, when they need to use
a computer, we want them to be able
to stand up and go use a computer.
Getting the kids so familiar and
so comfortable with technology,
with online access, with
fax machines and emails,
so it's second nature to them.
>>Sandra: For where these kids
are going to be in the future,
they're not going to have a choice
but to know about technology.
I mean you'd be surprised,
they really only need for me
to show them once how to do
anything, and they remember.
>>So the kids are on
the Internet right now.
And so, they are learning
the language that is spoken
in the country that
they are studying.
So we've got Sophia on a
German website right now.
>>Sophia: That means how are you.
>>Sandra: These guys over
here are looking at Russian.
>>Peggy: All right, thank you.
Let's do thank you.
Thank you very much.
[speaks Russian]
>>Student: Yeah, thank you very much.
>>Peggy: Thank you very much.
>>Sandra: It's just learning
more about what's new to bring
into the classroom
and going from there.
And really it's asking the
kids what they want to do
and being a facilitator for them.
>>Peggy: With a letter grade...
>>Narrator: For Peggy,
communication is the key
to the success of Sherman Oaks.
One of the school's
innovations is the mid-day block
where for 90 minutes every
day, the entire staff meets
to discuss everything from new
curricula to individual students.
>>Peggy: So from 11:30 to 1,
the teachers are off together.
That makes a big difference
in your community of learners.
It's simple, inexpensive, and
it makes all the difference.
This fosters an incredible amount of
dialogue and inquiry and discovery
and learning between teachers.
>>Osvaldo: She enjoys
writing and can write forever.
>>We have so much built
in into that mid-day block
that it's constant
communication going on.
>>Sandra: There's so much to learn.
There's always more I can learn.
Questioning, we're always
questioning, you know.
Don't ask why.
Ask why not.
>>Peggy: It happens when you have
a group of people that all believe
that what you're doing is right.
And it spills over.
And you give people opportunities
to also do what they think is right.
And they get bolder and
bolder and more confident.
You have to be able to reach
out to your colleagues.
You have to be able to go the extra
mile with our kids and our parents.
You have to see yourself
as taking an active role
and really turning this
whole industry upside down.
That's what we're in this for.
It's for the kids.
>>Narrator: For more
information on what works
in public education,
go to Edutopia.org.